I think there's a sharp dichotomy
between Republicans and Democrats on
several issues one is secularism versus
fundamentalism when you have many of the
Republican candidates raising their hand
when asked if they don't believe in
evolution and all the Democratic
candidates saying they do believe in
evolution when you have many Republicans
wanting to lower the wall of separation
between church and state and Democrats
many pandering as well to religious
constituencies but at least saying the
right words about separation of church
and state when you get the religious
groups misapplying Jesus message and
trying to recreate Jesus in their own
image if you look at the Republican
conception of Jesus he's a gun-toting
tax-cutting person who hates the poor I
mean nothing could be further from the
truth Jesus was a man of peace who loved
the poor and didn't have such nice views
about the rich something about the camel
going through a needle and it's bizarre
now now the Religious Right is trying to
recreate Thomas Jefferson and John Adams
and James Madison and George Washington
in their own image by pretending that
these were deeply religious Christians
who wanted to create a Christian society
in America so I think on the issues of
secularism versus religion on the issues
of environmentalism there are clear
differences between Democrats and
Republicans on the issues of minimum
wage and trying to help the poor on the
issues of immigration perhaps not as
sharply but there are there a big
differences I think none of the
candidates today wants to discuss the
big big big issues they're not good
political fodder they don't make good
bumper stickers and it's hard to
campaign on a
you